mr beast how do i go viral oh that's
easy to go viral you in this video i
interviewed mr beast collected all of
youtube's data and created a super smart
ai to find viral ideas instantly oh you
shouldn't have are you talking about me
no not you
check it out
hey google give me a viral video idea
okay here's one i only ate try not to
eat challenge food for 24 hours okay
it's a work in progress so the reason i
put this all together is to answer one
question how do you go viral on youtube
and maybe more specifically how do i go
viral on youtube we're gonna throw the
whole joe rogan kitchen sink at this
thing start from raw data work our way
up to ai and finally talk to the king of
virality himself in the hopes of
answering that single question how do
you but mostly me but also you go viral
to answer this we have to rewind the
clocks back a few years to may of 2019.
i just built a bot to collect trending
data from youtube and i found that it
was quite biased towards tv and old
media in fact you might have seen my
report in the news this youtuber called
coffee break made a video exposing the
trending tab now around that time
youtube promised to fix trending and
make it more fair to creators but to
keep them honest i continued to harvest
their data like my name was mark elliott
zuckerberg in fact not only did i
continue collecting us data i expanded
my operations to collect it all across
the world and after another year i found
that not only had youtube kept their
promise and made trending more fair also
nobody cares about trending anymore so i
just didn't release the video but it got
me thinking now that they fixed a lot of
problems with trending could we use that
data to learn how to go viral because it
turns out it's kind of hard to measure
viral because what's viral for me is a
million views if mr beast gets a million
views it's the worst day of his life
because of that we're going to use
trending on youtube as a rough measure
of virality it's not perfect it's not
even close but it's the best guess at
what youtube considers broadly appealing
viral content so let's jump into our
findings so here's what i did i plotted
all the data on a giant chart of who
trended how often how many views they
got when they went viral and here's what
my new year of collecting data showed
the most viral creator trending 168
times in the us who was canadian linus
tech tips give it up to him for stealing
our jobs the second most trending 165
times which is almost every other day
was espn and eating their way to third
and fourth rhett and link with good
mythical morning and good mythical more
and then coming in fifth place it was
the sports talk show skip and shannon
undisputed now the question is what do
all these successful channels have in
common not only do they upload fairly
often but they also all appeal to very
broad categories who likes tech
everybody who likes sports well
everybody who likes food challenges me
but also everybody which means our first
lesson is if you want to go viral
consistently you have to choose video
topics that appeal to large markets
which is kind of obvious but didn't stop
me from making a video about my obscure
data collection hobbies so that's number
one but then if we look globally beyond
the us we learn something else see if
you didn't know different countries have
different trending tab selections and
this time i wanted to measure not only
how many people went viral in the us but
went viral globally who is the most
viral creator around the world i found
that the number two creator globally was
mr beast kind of no surprise there but
coming in number one
beating him out narrowly was
kpop
that's right bts we're number one for
the year i collected this data and that
sort of makes sense right because music
is a universal language that can be
enjoyed by anyone plus k-pop low-key
slaps okay so it's not surprising then
that the top five most global trending
videos and we're talking individual
videos here they were all music videos
which again reflects how easily music
can cross barriers that regular language
just can't and that brings us to my
number two takeaway the world is
changing and youtube is a global
platform so it's not just about
appealing to what's viral in the united
states but a global audience as well now
it's clear from this data going viral is
hugely based on the broadest topics and
getting the right ideas but to be honest
i'm only human and i could try to sit
down and think of good ideas myself but
why do that when i can build a robot to
do it for me but i mean why stop there
why should i even build the robot at all
when i can barely code so instead i
found a much smarter guy than myself
eden meyer to do it for me he's an ai
youtuber who should go check out link
below but it brings me to a third lesson
of going viral sometimes your ideas are
a little too big and you just need to
ask for help that's alright i really
have no data to support that but it just
kind of seems like good advice and once
he finished putting all our data into a
super smart ai we ended up with this
check this out maxwell hey google give
me a viral idea okay here's one pets
versus adults react to drunk versus
spent toys
that's the best you can do that's
terrible but wait it's thinking give it
a second hey google give me another
viral idea okay here's one the best
smartphone you won't buy you gotta admit
that's not bad yeah it's okay
but even a blind ai can find a nut once
in a while what i don't know that's one
of your human sayings right no the
saying is it's a blind squirrel that
finds a nut once in a while what do
squirrels have to do with this nothing
look you get me all messed up here look
here's here's another one okay one more
time i'll prove it to you that this
isn't just luck okay google give me one
more okay here's one i hydro dipped my
diamond play button and now i'm in hell
honestly the truth was slowly dawning on
me that even if i could get that ai to
give me great ideas all the time i
realized they're based on what's gone
viral in the past and i wanted to know
what would go viral in the future and so
with no other options i called up mr
beast and i finally asked him the
burning question that everyone's
wondering right now i found out that
globally you were the number two channel
right behind bts wait really bts doesn't
even post ever how does it feel to be
the number two most viral youtuber
uh in that for 2021 no 2020. oh well i
don't count that year
i only had one channel back then that's
that's lame i want i demand a recount
yeah yeah the date is still coming in on
2021 okay we'll get that next year
okay but seriously thanks for coming on
i really appreciate it and i guess my
big question is how do you go viral
consistently do you want the hour-long
answer or the super short answer uh
whatever the true answer is i guess can
you say it is it short is the true
answer short i ca the thing is like i
can give you a high level or the
we'll give you a high level so
essentially for us the way i like to
look at it is if if we if i spend me and
my team spend like 10 times more time
than everyone else brainstorming ideas
which would probably at this point spend
a hundred times more time than everyone
else uh we spend half a million to a
million dollars video whereas normal
people are spending like a thousand or
ten thousand is an expensive video now
and we just you know sometimes we're
filming for three or four days like 10
hours a day you know 30 40 hours of
filming plus months of setup whereas
most creators probably film for a couple
hours and set up for a day i think for
us you know by always doing all those
things it just distinctively sets it so
far apart that it's basically in my head
it's like why would you not watch it you
know what i mean so is this just the
meme of like quality content like
quality over quantity but then you're
doing the quantity too though it seems
like you upload relatively a lot yeah
well so that's where
well i guess
man you're about to make me just start a
college class here on this yeah so
essentially yes at the end of the day if
you boil it down what youtube wants is
they want people to click on a video and
they want to watch it like at its core
that's what it is now you can like draw
little lines and go as deep as you want
and to how to get people to click and
how to get people to watch i mean
essentially by studying the algorithm
you'll learn that you're more studying
human psychology right what do humans
want to watch what do they find enjoying
not because anytime you say the word
algorithm just replace it with audience
and it works perfectly like the
algorithm didn't like that video no the
audience didn't like that video no you
know because literally that's it if
people are clicking and watching then it
gets promoted more and that's all that's
literally all the algorithm does is
reflect what the people want 280 and if
you deny that you just make terrible
videos that are trying to find a
scapegoat like uh i mean there's a
reason everyone loves youtube and you
know spends hours every single day on it
so so far in this video i've talked a
lot about finding the right idea the
right title because that's what i have a
lot of data on but that just gets people
to click there's this whole other side
and people have tried to copy your
thumbnail strategy copy your title
strategy but you're a master of audience
retention as well of keeping people on
the video i guess it's delivering on the
video but how do you hold people for so
long and what are other people doing
that's killing their retention oh gosh
where do you begin i mean we'll start at
the beginning essentially your title and
thumbnail set expectations and at the
very beginning of the video to minimize
drop-off you want to assure them that
those expectations are being met if you
click on a video where you know uh of
his where it's like tether is a scam and
then at the very beginning he starts
talking about literally anything else
then you're like oh this is bull this
isn't what i clicked on but if at the
very start of the video you go tether is
a scam and i'm going to teach you why
then it's like okay you match the
expectation so at the very beginning
match the expectations and then you want
to exceed them so you want to assure
people that what they clicked on that's
what they're getting and then blow their
mind and be like but you're also getting
even more that's how you you lower drop
off which a lot of people sometimes it
takes like 20 seconds to really meet the
expectations and so you lose like that's
where you're going to lose everyone
everyone's videos start like this and
then it levels off so you want to reduce
the amount of people that click off on
the audience retention graph i hope
you're popping up graphs while i'm
saying this so so it's easier for people
to visualize but so then once you get it
to level off it's just how do you keep
it level until the end of the video and
that's where you you want to have you
basically want to remove every dull
moment you probably want to find the 10
most critical people you know make them
watch the video and just roast it you
wanna i personally i enjoy
i enjoy having people watch the videos
and watching them there's some things
you can do where like you basically pay
people to watch the videos on frame and
then just have them record it and i love
just seeing like when they pick up their
phones and when they get bored and like
you know certain things like if i just
talk to a camera for 10 seconds without
a cut like a lot of people will just
like get bored or they'll lose interest
so like having a b cam and a c cam and
just you can just talk for 10 seconds
but three seconds in cutting to a b cam
and then a c cam like now it's more
interesting even though it's essentially
the same thing and not that crazy but
you want to have good pacing typically
having a payoff at the end keep some
right last sleep circle wins 10 grand if
there is a low moment halfway through
you're going to watch to the end because
you want to see who wins the 10 grand um
so having a good payoff at the end i
mean dude i don't even know i i could
talk about this for like hours but yeah
i feel like so many creators don't think
about this they just start and they just
kind of ramble on i know i've caught
myself doing this a minute has gone by i
haven't done anything i'm just starting
to get in the video and you see that in
the retention graph you just see that
huge dip and i have to remind myself to
go and like re-go to these principles
but obviously you've given a lot of
advice to other creators but i know
firsthand there's a difference between
hearing something and doing it what
piece of advice do you find yourself
repeating over and over to creators and
they're just not getting it
oh boy a lot you know so here's a fun
story i actually i mentor this one guy
just for fun i started uh he was a
friend medium-sized youtuber he was
doing like i think he was doing twenty
thousand like he tenth a month in
revenue like ten thousand on one channel
and like eight thousand a month on
another channel and um this month he
actually just had his highest revenue
month ever uh he did four hundred
thousand dollars in revenue um and just
by like listening to what i i taught him
i know we were able to like 20 x's
revenue uh and i was just like with me
just once a week just telling him he was
an idiot and what to do uh and i do that
for a lot of people i just counsel
people for fun and help them blow up
their channels a lot of times people
oh boy it's like they think their videos
are better than they are honestly and
they don't jimmy tell them i mean they
do and and you have to like you have to
that and they have horrible friend
groups because you really are like the
type of youtubers you hang around and so
like a lot of times i'm just like what
you're saying is wrong who told you this
they're like oh this guy this guy and
it's like well they're wrong it's not
true and so it's getting people with the
right youtuber friend group that aren't
[ __ ] and will actually tell them when
their content's bad and like actually
roast it and and help them get better in
a nice positive way and then usually
it's hiring an editor honestly uploading
less videos and just making them better
it's much easier to get five million
views on one video than 50 000 views on
100 videos takes way less effort to get
5 million views in one video so it's
like applying a lot of these principles
like that and also getting it where it's
content that they enjoy a lot of people
aren't willing to put in 10 hours days
because they don't like what they're
doing so it's finding what they enjoy
because it is like a long grind like
you're doing for years not months so if
you don't enjoy it then you're going to
burn out and that so like that's usually
the first thing it's like figuring out
like what are the things you're
currently doing that you don't want to
do and like let's figure out a way to
get someone else to do it in the next
five months so you actually get out of
bed excited and i always thought you
were the type to like you're like making
sure like okay i got to get to my point
in like 10 seconds and then i got to get
like the like the outros
well i mean that's but that's stuff you
can you do later and you can do that no
matter what the video is you can do that
right it's like i mean we've done videos
where i've ran from the military where i
buried myself for 50 hours where i mean
everything even back in the day like q
and a's that have gone viral or or other
stuff like you can make anything work
but at the end of the day it's got to be
like interesting to the audience
original and just good you know what i
mean and if you hit those like you can
figure out a good intro and outro you
know what i mean yeah
one of the things i think you're doing
better than anyone is growing a team um
i think you're creating the
infrastructure around you to make videos
which like i think a lot of youtubers
are like solo acts and they maybe pride
themselves on that but you're crushing
it with doing your thing how much do you
think your success is just being a
talented youtuber versus the team you've
been able to build well it's hard
because being uh
it's like it's a weird balance because i
would never i you know i used to save up
a dollar a day like the my first
microphone i had to save up for three
months to buy and you know we didn't
have anybody it was i had a single mom
raising me and my my brother and sister
so um it's like that relentless
obsession of youtube and reinvesting got
us to that point and so building the
team to lev like if i didn't know how to
go viral it doesn't matter if i had a
thousand employees it wouldn't
not give you so it was i think for me it
was it was good that i got a really
strong foundation on how youtube works
and how the style of videos i wanted and
everything before i scaled up the team
if that makes any sense i just want to
make sure that's clear because i've seen
people try to build the team without
foundation and knowing how to do well
and that it you know it just oh that's
interesting yeah they try to build it
before basically it's ready to be
like and so that's what gave me the
confidence to hire people and that's why
i'm able to run my company at really
thin margins because i have faith and i
i know that if we film this video it
will do well just because i've spent a
decade of my life hyper-obsessing over
youtube and i have a good pulse on it
but if you didn't have that then you
wouldn't know like you wouldn't be able
to spend 4 million on a squid game
because you might lose 2 million bucks
and then you can't pay your people so
it's like but anyways yeah it's i don't
even remember the original question but
of course yeah if i didn't have these
people i i couldn't do half the stuff i
do i mean we we have
in my opinion the best people in the
industry working here and i love them to
death here's my question if we took you
took your brain right now and put it
into a guy with no money and no
subscribers so you can't give away money
you can't make a million dollar giveaway
video how long would it take you to get
to 1 million subscribers
probably
three months maybe four from zero easily
three or four months like if that's all
that guy was doing i mean like
let me think
i would probably just walk across
america that would get me on the map and
then just do something earlier
yeah some
some other zero dollar uh extreme
challenges get some attention take that
money i don't know maybe make a line of
paper clips i think those are cheap and
stretch it across the state or something
and then i i you know um something you
know that i'd try to swim from like
europe to africa that would be a cool
stunt or something i've thought about
this before that would pop off dude a
thumbnail of me just swimming in the
middle of the ocean like i don't want to
do it now because they're easier stuff
but i would do it like straight at your
mouth it's like four four miles or
something no big deal yeah but then you
you know imagine a title i swear from
europe to africa like that would pop off
uh or i swim across the ocean or
something i mean yeah easily like i
could figure out a blueprint and then
i'd just suffer for four months and then
i'd have a million subscribers
i always wonder what are some ideas
because you have like at this point you
have a brand you have a whole thing i'm
sure you think of ideas all the time
that just don't fit what you are for
whatever reason what are some like
killer ideas that you've had that you're
like
it just doesn't work
i can read yourself i've got like 9 000
video ideas sitting here i i just want
to hear sort of like what pops in your
brain so even if it's like even if you
don't think it it like i just want to
think like what are you brainstorming i
i rode a roller coaster without a
seatbelt i don't know why that one's
there um
uh i wouldn't do this one but i made a
homeless man a millionaire uh fly first
to fly around the world one's a private
jet uh
i i can't read some of these uh uh i
survived 24 hours in the world's deepest
cave would you rather have half a
million dollars or a private island last
leave haunted house food's under k i
opened a restaurant that only served
money that's a funny one i opened a free
tesla dealership i heard real criminals
these feel like mr beast videos though
they're very like this is free this is
the twist this is first to do this gets
it i mean that's what we're on idea 5443
i mean i don't know it's just like
random ones i could uh scroll up
complete this race 100k here let me
scroll up uh i bought the like
we legit just seven oh my gosh that's
insane wow so is that what you read now
instead of a dictionary you just read
that now and like look for ideas well so
i i have some friends that help
basically what i found is like yeah like
i you heard the dictionary story i work
well off inspiration and so i found it'd
be better just to kind of have people
come up with ideas roughly and then i
ingest them because dude half those
ideas aren't good and i wouldn't film
but then when i read them it inspires me
and i'm like no first the finished race
100 like that's too simple but first
person to climb a mountain wins 100
grand is good and so i like when people
just give me inspiration and then i just
what makes one good and the other bad
i think running a race is like people
have done that it's like generic it's
whatever but like first to climb
mountain and like a thumbnail of someone
climb inside of a mountain and the
thought of someone climbing a mountain
is extreme like the that's adrenaline
it's interesting like to me climbing a
mountain is more interesting than
running a marathon with all this data
your your brain is sort of a tuned
algorithm itself of like
like evaluating i think it's so
interesting watching you evaluate like
titles actually i was curious how do you
think that that title what i told you
earlier how to go viral feat mr beast
will do do you think there's a better
title um
i think
how to go viral featuring mr beast i
think that would work i think
a lot of like colin sameer's video i
mean got five million views and um yeah
i think my face can pull some views so
i mean what's your most video like a
million two million three million three
million yeah then by those standards it
would do pretty well like i've seen
plenty of videos from my face to pull a
couple million views so i think you
would be happy with it but if you're
trying to get like a 50 million view
video i don't i don't think it would
work you know like how does the equation
change this is the point of the video
hold on this is the heartbeat of the
video how does the equation change from
like hey i want to get a cute little i
know for you it's like that's five
million views how do you go from that to
like i want to get a 50 million view
video what is the difference in the way
you think about those two things you
need something hey original how to go
viral is probably it's not something
like super original you like you need a
really strong opinion probably like you
need to say like like what you're saying
is like i like bananas and what you need
is bananas are the best goddamn food on
the planet like that's the type of
opinion you need like you need something
like how to get a hundred million views
on youtube not even that that's not
strong enough you need something that
makes people go what the [ __ ] you know
and like click you know what i mean
dude i want to click whatever video
you're selling me right now dude yes
that video that's what i want to watch
yeah but that's hyper specific to you
but you see what i'm saying it needs to
be extreme it needs to be like how to go
viral that's not gonna cause someone to
go damn if i don't click that i'm not
gonna be able to sleep at night you need
something that legit will have people be
like
what the [ __ ] did he say in that video
what the [ __ ] i need to know you know
that is how i describe to some people
like um what makes of like like a really
great video is you feel like the feeling
of i can't look away
that is a very specific emotion that is
most videos do not have like like the
vast major you like you very rarely run
into a video where you go i can't stop
watching so i recently look i'm just
gonna be honest here jimmy i also
brought you here for a bit of a
confrontation i recently heard you refer
to your warehouse as a 10 million dollar
studio and i don't want to get lawyers
involved but uh you know i had it first
and this isn't really a question as much
as it is a legal threat so do you have
any comments on that well i think we
actually paid 11 million so i can just
change it to like what the 10 no
you can take the 10 title i'll take the
11.
it's just 10 sounded better i'm calling
bts right now dude i'm going to call bts
and ask them these questions
are you tracking other languages or just
english i'm tracking around the so
whatever appears on all the different
like yeah so this year you represent
this year because we're trending in
espanol now with the espanol channel and
gaming and reacts are always trending so
that's a huge thing i wanted to ask you
about actually is i've taken notice of
that i um is that a 2021 thing
yeah i mean that was like four months
ago it it's gained three million
subscribers a month for like like it's
insane you've never been growing faster
no i mean like we think i think we did
20 million subscribers last month across
all the channels oh my gosh
yeah that and probably two billion views
now and it's just going up month over
month because once you have 40 channels
if they're all pulling 100 plus million
views a month it gets pretty crazy well
so back to the viral thing pull up
mysteries gaming and espino that that's
that answers your question right we
didn't promote that channel that that
first video on that channel got like a
hundred thousand views now read off how
many views it's on now it's got 10
million views exactly all organic from
the algorithm it literally in the second
video got like a hundred thousand views
day one i think as well and it's on 11
million views because and these these
are dub videos these aren't even the
original hot like best quality versions
of them but because these videos had 70
percent retention despite being dubbed
they had really good thumbnails and they
were just interesting [ __ ]
even though it's a completely different
language on a brand new channel with no
promotion they still went super viral
and that's where like i hate when people
are like well the video only does well
because you're popular we can go into
new languages with people who have never
heard of me and still get giant 10
million view videos just because the
videos are good that's the big thing
that i'm trying to break down in this
video is understanding that's the
science of virality that i'm talking
about is forget about the brand name
forget about people are so focused on oh
you only can do that because you're mr
beast you only can do that because you
already have a million subscribers on my
main channel like one percent of my my
views are from mexico or uh whatever
it's like a very none of my views are
from south america right and on at mr
beast espanol 1.3 of my viewership is
american and it's all mexico colombia
argentina these are people who literally
have never even heard of me before and
these videos are still going super viral
it's all about it's just about they
didn't have access to you before now
they can be given 70 retention videos of
you and you just pop off because of it
exactly and it's not because they know
who i am it's just because the videos
are good they just are they're
interesting they have good retention
they have good pacing you can't find
them anywhere else and you know the last
the thing i want to leave people with is
people think it's like oh well um it's
all like ctr and stuff like that but a
big thing that everyone underestimates
is it's what what was your experience
with your last video if people loved
your the last video of yours that they
watch they're more likely to watch your
next one and that's something that
people take
for granted because like we'll you know
we'll get trending and i'll notice a
comment from someone like we'll just
pull it in like edward jobs right and
everyone jobs will comment oh my gosh
i've i've never seen mr beast before
this was really cool and then you can
search their username like three hours
later and they'll go oh my gosh i just
watched eight videos like where has this
been all my life i just watched him give
away a hundred thousand dollars play a
million dollar game a hide and seek to
the world's largest lego tower do this
this and this and it's because see
that's the effect you want most people
when they watch for the youtubers
watching this when people watch your
video they go okay that was good but
like that's enough of of you for the day
like it was it was all right right
where's what you want is them to go holy
crap that was crazy oh my god what's
that holy crap that was crazy oh my god
and they just and they watched ten
videos not one and they need like a week
break because it was so ah that they
have to recharge you know what i mean
that's that's what you're going for that
data can't describe and like i don't
i've never heard anyone talk about that
but that that is it that's how you get
these high view counts because people
watch 10 videos not one you know mr
beast thank you for coming on the show
listen let me be honest i've always
wanted to hang up on a uh on a on a
famous person before so uh bye
i was about to try to beat him
oh wow i felt as good as i thought it
would honestly what a rush
well big thanks to mr beast i hope you
guys learned something and i'll see you
in the next one